[Music]
hey guys in this video we're going to
talk about sources prophesied killer the
valonqar and who that person might be
valonqar in case you don't know is a
very important part omegas prophecy in
books although almost everything Maggy
the Frog told Cersei on the show already
came true there's this one part of the
prophecy they'll show left out but
excited to eventually foreshadow in
season 7 premiere it's the prophecy of
the valonqar in A Song of Ice and Fire a
series of epic fantasy novels on which
the game eternal series is based miss
prophecy beside including everything in
the show feature also includes the line
and then your tears around you the
valonqar shall wrap his sense about your
pale white throat and choke the life
from you the Verde Ellen carrying high
Valyrian means little brighter
Cersei took this to mean Tyrion which is
part of why she hates him so much the
identity of search this prophesied
valonqar has been heavily debated among
the fans and numerous suggestions have
been made as far material Jemmy being
the most suitable choices as their
sources younger brothers but the
valonqar prophecy is most likely not
that simple if you read the prophecy
without making the same mistake Cersei
does there's plenty of people who fit
what it actually says not only Tyrion
and Jaime George are morons characters
are always misinterpreting prophecies in
particular signals readers take the
valonqar section out of context and
think it could be one where siblings
either Jaime or Tyrion let's take a
quick look at the well anchor prophecy
once again and then your tears around
you dwelling car shall wrap his sense
about your pale white throat and choke
the life from you not how it says the
valonqar
meaning the younger brighter not your
younger brother or a younger brother but
the title brother already established by
the context Circe immediately assumes
it's centered around her even at this
young age she already hates her younger
brother Tyrion and leaps at the chance
to hate him more having come to this
conclusion she treats the valonqar is
some kind of dread title for a monster
of her younger brother not only could
the younger brother the valonqar be any
male in the story who has an older
sibling but it can also be any female in
the story who has an older sibling as
well how well divert valonqar comes from
high Valyrian a language that is not
really into gender specificities as we
learned in season 7
so this younger brother could very well
be a younger sister the prophecy of the
prince that was promised also comes from
high Valyrian and as we learn it
neutral meaning that as Miss Amy said it
the proper translation of the prophecy
would be the prince or princess that was
promised will bring you dawn therefore
an actual translation the well incur
prophecy might also be gender-neutral
with a possibility of both younger
brother and younger sister possibly
being the valonqar
search they think it's Tyrion the
phantom think it's Jaime Lannister
services to him brother that is
technically her younger brother as he
was born a few minutes after her as
already said my previous video
supporting evidence to this theory could
also be both Jaime and Cersei statement
just like they were born they will die
together as well they believe their
deaths are linked they both claimed that
because they came into the world
together they will leave it together as
well examples include Jaime statement
that he cannot die while Cersei lives we
will die together as we were born
together Jaime finished Circe says if he
were dead I would know it we came into
this world together uncle he would not
go without me
perhaps Jaime truly is the prophesied
valonqar which might have even been
foreshadowed in a season 7 premiere
above sources headed the words the neck
just about Jaime the fingers well Jamie
wrap his fingers around serves his neck
perhaps many the Frog prophesied to
Cersei the dwelling car younger brother
will kill her but she did not say your
well in car your brother will kill you
and if the world Balan car is gender
neutral then it means that the valonqar
could possibly be anyone in story who's
got an older sibling it could be anyone
from Arya Stark with Cersei on her list
so Danny who is also someone's little
sibling and will probably want to put an
end to Cersei after the betrayal she's
done in the season 7 finale as a matter
of fact the official gammatron season 7
episode 7 scripts that are on display
for the public to see the Writers Guild
of America West libraries seem to be
indicating that Dany might be sources
prophesied valonqar who wanted to put an
end to her reign and her life altogether
for the season 7 finale the script reads
at one point
Cersei stares at her enemy this
baby-faced observer who's can't take
what's hers is the old Cersei prophecy
actually about Danny at the beginning of
season five year treated with the cold
open that featured a flashback in which
hamsters is given a dark prophecy by
Maggie the Frog who basically tells her
who she marry and how many children will
she have all of it came true
Maggie also tells her that all her
children will die which also came true
but it's not all sir she was told that
she'll be observed by a younger woman as
the ruler of the Seven Kingdoms
Meggie said he will never read The
Prince she will let the king you
Queen 4 time there comes another younger
more beautiful to cast it down and take
all the whole dear Meggie also revealed
to Cersei that the king will have 20
children and sir civil hell 3 gold will
be their crowns gold their shrouds
almost all the prophets already proved
to be quite accurate
Cersei did not feed the prince rhaegar
targaryen as she wanted she married the
King Robert Baratheon
they both had children but not together
King Robert father 20 and Queen Cersei
had rich Amy and violent it stared 2 out
of 3 stars children were still alive by
an end of season 6 they all had their
golden crowns and shrouds but who it's
going to be this younger more beautiful
Queen that will cast her sit down and
take all she holds Cersei as well as
most viewers thought this was a
reference to Queen Margaery Tyrell who
married two officers his sons after
initially being married to Renly
Baratheon Margaery firstly married
Joffrey in order to become the queen and
she did become one but not for too long
not even for a day Joffrey was poisoned
in a wedding celebration and Margie was
not in a position to press the issue of
being the queen since it was not a good
time as the capital and royal family was
morning upon failing two times to become
an actual Queen Margaery finally becomes
queen of the Seven Kingdoms upon
marrying Cersei Zadar sentiment Cersei
as well as most of the fence so Margaery
as this prophesied younger and more
beautiful queen that will alter of
Cersei Cersei was the queen of the Seven
Kingdoms until her sons came to the
throne and weds Margaery Tyrell saw
margery did in some sense order of
Cersei from being the queen of the Seven
Kingdoms but she certainly is not the
prophesied one as that the answers is
the one who eradicated her and took the
throne for herself sir she was able to
vanquish Margaery all the Tyrells and a
whole lot of other citizens of Inns
landing and she said wildfire to the
great Sept of Baelor in the season six
finale
however the script from sources first
meeting with Dane in season seven makes
it seem she may not be out of the woods
just yet in avoiding that last bit of
the prophecy will be the queen for a
time then comes another younger more
beautiful to cast it down and take all
holder for season 7 episode 7 the script
reads at one point search the stairs at
our enemy this baby-faced usurper who's
come to take what's hers the script does
seem to support any being the prophesied
younger more beautiful Queen that alert
or Cersei but it does not necessarily
mean that she will be searched this
bunker it doesn't necessarily mean that
then it will be sad putting an end to
the math Queen's reign also put an end
to her life although it does not
necessarily mean she will not although I
personally don't see it happening
not that Danny won't
Kassar sit down in the wardrober as a
matter of fact she most likely will be
that Queen as the official script
supports it but I don't see Danny being
the one to put an end to serves his life
it's gotta be either Jamie or Aria but
that's just me it could also be urine it
could also be sensor it could be Jon
Snow
it could be many characters what we can
say for sure is that in the official
script search this is Danny as the
prophesied Queen that will cast her down
and take all she holds now that I
mentioned young graduate that character
is also on top of my list as who might
be the valonqar and here's why Euron
Greyjoy is on his way back to King's
Landing with the Cullen company front
official tease the spin up the search
they will be in a big trouble once yeren
returns milena harry an actress who
played Cersei describing it with this
statement as usual if it sir says she's
trapped in a web of her own making
Cersei is being trapped in your skin
that she so foolishly let her and make a
contract at the comic company and making
him so powerful over all vilas big said
this about his character yearn in season
8 urine wants to become the king of the
Seven Kingdoms yet he's also
blackmailing Cersei you're on his
blackmailing search there the gulling
company and his own fleet Cersei has to
marry urine or he will leave it his
fleet and turn the gallant company
against her as it might be searched -
who paid them but it's turned who made a
deal with them and it's urine whose name
is on the contract
that's why she's trapped in the web of
her own making and that's how he earned
his blackmailing her Cersei will have to
marry earned all your ingredients is to
become the king of the Seven Kingdoms
and if search that does not make him one
he will kill her and become one which
was actually heavily foreshadowed in
season seven so I would not be surprised
if that happens remember what your
instead of sir seven he greets her in
the throne room of King's Landing in the
season 7 premiere ever since I was a
little boy I wanted to grow up and marry
the most beautiful woman in the world so
here I am with a thousand ships and two
good hands the fact that he's
specifically stating to Cersei that he
has two hands with Jaime present in the
same room is obviously a stab at Jamie
and his relationship with Cersei but
might also be a hint that urine is the
valonqar because remember the valonqar
shall wrap his hands around Cersei's
pale white throat and choke the life
from her there's also one more hint
hidden in the books supporting a theory
of Kieran being sources valonqar inserts
as Jim says she visits Maggie she wants
to speak to youngsters
and tell her it's mistake to speak to
the witch much chickened out because the
energy she has no tongue
the hint of urine being the valonqar
here is in the fact that sir she has no
tongue in her dreams and visiting Maggie
and as we all know urine is usually the
one who cuts tongues in our story none
of the crew members on a ship silence
has tongue you don't cut it out each of
them by himself
I believe all of this combined is
building to the fact that urine will
kill sir sets a point although I don't
think it will actually be earned I think
it will be already aware in your own
space Maisie Williams an actress who
plays sorry what is this about a
character there's this split vitória
between trying to be who she wants to be
getting back to back to that naivete and
innocence with her family and her
unfinished business what this means is
that our evil stick with her family and
fight for Winterfell against the night
king in Episode three but feminine fell
false and when Arya learned so sir says
yet another betrayal over her family
she'll have to stay a temporary goodbye
to her family and go on to finish her
infamous list arriving to King's Landing
are you'll find services surrounded by
all those trying to get best out of her
you're on being the most prominent one
trying to find a way to get close to
search the without being killed on sight
by the mountain sources protect her at
all times sari will decide it's best for
her to kill yearn and take his face and
it's very get a chance to get to Cersei
keep it in mind that by this time your
inserts are not the only lies but
probably husband and wife as well since
her she'll be trapped in marry him or
otherwise he's going to abandon her so
Aria kills your take is facing goes to
Cersei chambers
Cersei thinking it's one of those nights
she has danger now that they're husband
and wife
Cersei let's yearn in order to the
mountain to leave the room once in
bedroom and just before they start doing
their husband my duties storm will start
choking Cersei urine is the valonqar but
it's actually Aria we're in your own
space once again this is just a theory
it could be pretty much anyone in story
although it will probably be one of
these three Jaime RER yearned and as
always I hope you guys enjoyed this
video if you did please make sure to
subscribe to our Channel and I hope to
see you in the next one peace